foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
stands equal before the law
no amount of money and no amount of
power changes that enduring American
principle
[Music]
thank you
this is basically a hush money payment
to influence the outcome of the election
it's not at all clear that if all these
Mistresses were known to the public he
would have lost a single vote he may
have even gained votes
foreign
I think it's kind of questioned right
now with regard to how persuasive it
will be to the jury they have to find
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and the
accusers here Michael Cohen who's
convicted felon he's got contradictions
in his past Stormy Daniels of
pornography a person that's not a person
who instantly comes with great
discredibility but that's why we have a
jury in the rule of law
[Music]
um
even if he's convicted he could still
run for office Bill Clinton basically
was accused of something similar but
that didn't really impede his
credibility with the public whatsoever
and in fact once he left office he
really didn't lose favor so I don't
think that this this conviction on its
own is going to say well I have a whole
new understanding of Mr Trump
foreign